coming off of a pretty pretty good
season in oklahoma
you know playing good football knowing
you know what it takes uh to be good at
that level um bringing that hopefully
bringing that into this season obviously
but i think you know it's going to take
a lot of reps between me and the guys
getting on the same page
you know obviously this is coach
kingsbury's first year so
just finding that finding that groove
and once we do i think we can be pretty
dangerous
calvin murray cardinals rookie
quarterback the question is how long
will it take him to find the groove
especially when they compete with the
likes the rams seahawks and 49ers chris
but look so far so good for kylie murray
it's going to be fascinating to see week
one what he does lions come to town how
is he going to look against an nfl
caliber defense when it's full speed
full go game that counts yeah no i i
mean we're all going to be excited for
that i mean that's why the arizona
cardinals can kind of be going to be uh
must-watch football you know and and hey
we got in that whole scrambling
quarterback conversation right with kyla
murray the other day had a lot of people
you know coming at you and i oh how do
you know he's one of the best scramblers
in football yet he hasn't even played a
game listen this is one of the greatest
runners in the history of the sport to
come in running the football at the
quarterback position so yes i don't know
i think he's gonna be able to run 70
yard touchdowns like he did at oklahoma
but i'm pretty confident he will be in
the conversation for one of the best
scrambling quarterbacks and the best
running quarterbacks in football year
one right away so that's where it's
going to be dangerous and then can they
just get somebody else on that offense
to be dangerous with him right that's my
other question larry i mean uh we know
uh the running back um i'm biking on his
first david johnson thank you i've
always said larry johnson david johnson
we certainly know he's top-notch it can
make a whole lot of plays but who's
going to be that receiver in the pass
game that becomes the go-to guy
that he has that connection with or who
cliff kingsbury is going to design a lot
of the big-time place where i know larry
fitzgerald's really good but he's not
dangerous that way anymore so those are
the things i'm excited to see with kyle
murray and that cardinals offense
hey and the must-watch tv element
extends to the pre-season because
there's a nationally televised
pre-season game against the raiders
which means the hard knocks cameras may
be picking up some contrary story lines
as well maybe some swear words from john
gruden as he runs circles around the
oakland raiders defense there also may
be some la rams in hard knocks because
they're talking about joint practices
between the raiders and the rams and one
of the big story lines for the rams
quarterback jared goff specifically his
future with the team as driven by the
contract he's going to want sean mcveigh
the coach of the rams sat down with fred
rogen of nbc's la affiliate and listen
to what summer mcveigh had to say about
his quarterback jared goff here it is
i don't know how often you check online
and hear what the pundits say one
suggested that you know the thing about
jared goff is there'll be a point in
time where you're just going to get rid
of them because you're going to bring
somebody in here who's younger and be
your kind of guy
now to me i thought that was insane you
can tell me if it is because
you've developed him into the one of the
top quarterbacks in the game yeah he's
developed himself into that and you know
we've been able to work together really
well over the last couple years i can
assure you that it's not going to happen
ain't going anywhere
okay first of all fred feel free to call
me out if you're going to take one of my
arguments and second of all you
oversimplified it the point is this
will the rams pay jared goff what he
wants or will they be the first team to
say we're just not going that far we
think we have other alternatives to
whatever you're going to want whether
it's 35 million 38 million 40 million a
year and when we look at everything that
sean mcvay has been saying about jared
goff we only played a very small clip of
it he goes on to be very effusive about
jared goff in that interview and he was
very effusive about jared goff yesterday
when talking with reporters chris one of
the top rules of negotiation don't give
the agent extra ammunition to say here's
why we want 40 million a year look at
what sean mcvay's saying about it yeah
well i think sean mcvay's more worried
about the other conversation that's
going on about jared goff right now
which is you know you know how good is
jared goff how great is he he's trying
to defend his quarterback listen he's
done a lot of good things with jared
goff yes you know do i think he's a top
10 talent in the nfl no i certainly
don't do i think he can make a
enough game-changing plays just with his
physical ability no i don't but he can
still win football games as we've seen
and mcveigh is going to back his
quarterback through and through i mean
what do we expect him to say here first
of all so that's where i look at it uh
and i just think there's going to be too
much public pressure in the end of the
day for the rams and they will give goff
somewhat close to what he gets i just
think that'll happen even though i think
the rams are the type of team that would
think about it like you're saying
it all comes down to how much he wants
though that's the key and the stuff
mcvay is saying isn't going to make him
want less that's for sure
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports